[Musique]
attention à la il faut la réussir cette
expérience et abribat on regarde comme
je le fais bien là ça descend ça remonte
oui faut le refaire encore doit appuyer
avec trubion mais j'appuie bien là
pratiquement à volonté hop le l'union en
bas hop il est en bas remonte studio
ouais voilà il remonte on n'est pas
byzance a dit c'est formidable mais tout
le monde peut le faire au fond le monde
peut le faire
bonjour à tous et à toutes ah oui
bonjour il était en train de vous
préparer un un petit truc étonnant alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut un bocal c'est bien
ça oui de lolo tout simplement et une
simple ampoule place et de ses patientes
bull électrique non non non l'eau
distillée toute simple alors comment
vous pouvez réaliser ça vous devez cas
c'est l'un des bouts de lampes ou bon
jusqu'ici c'est pas très compliqué
ensuite il faut vider goutte à goutte
le liquide qui se trouvent dans l'ems
poule en leur nom comme ça goûte à goûte
bien jusqu'à ce que vous puissiez
obtenir un équilibre qui vous permettent
de laisser l'an poule à la surface de
l'eau car si vous mettez l'emploi comme
ça elle ira directement au fond
entraînée par le poids pour ça que l'on
vide gouda coûte le liquide jusqu'à
trouver cet équilibre que tout qu'encore
un merveilleusement réalisés tels que
vous pouvez voir ici
et ce alors j'ai eu du mal à le faire
goutte à goutte c'est un petit peu
longue mais enfin on y arrive très bien
ensuite le problème est simple
enfin simple au des douze aurait
peut-être quelques difficultés mais on
finit par y arriver très bien vous
mettez votre main bien à plat sur le
goulot de la bouteille ou au de cet
engin là et puis vous appuyer fortement
jusqu'à ce que le ludion aille au fond
alors je recommence à marcher up lui du
haut en bas
le voilà en bas il peut il rester vous
voyez il y reste
et maintenant je le laisse remonter
doucement up après sa facile amusant
alors je vous conseille de peindre le
medion de la couleur qui vous plaît
bleus voient des sortes et puis c'est
plus joli en tes jeunes moi c'est très
joli extraordinaire ce que tu m'as
réalisa je peux je peux te faire un
baiser je te faire baiser mais aussi de
sorte d'inventeurs content d'eux mêmes
sommes ravis révèle-t-elle dis donc tu
je suis désolé de te dire ça mais j'ai
des choses à avoir avec 900 damian vous
voulez vous jouer à tous les deux tous
ensemble a pas contraindre à une petite
chose un costume à nos jeunes quand je
monte je m'en vais on t'appellera oui
mais à aller vite on a tous les deux lui
il savait bien ce que vous avez vu les
rebelles talibans
[Musique]
fays oui tu peux venir
baa a cette fois trop difficile à asia
tu es bon eh bien mon chien fabrice je
vais me permettre de commencer ce point
commun tu sais nous et nous avons chacun
une petite histoire à te raconter bon
nous sommes des objets des animaux
n'importe quoi mais nous avons tous les
trois un point commun entre nous oui
alors voilà alors aujourd'hui moi je
suis un crabe du sel et ses crap qu'on
découvre sous les rochers sur la plage
qui qui s'enfonce dans le sable quand on
vient à les toucher tu vois et je suis
un crack qui marche un petit peu de
biais de travers je cours je cours dans
les vagues
et puis j'ai l'air comme ça inoffensif
mais faut pas s'y fier tiens tu na kham
tu n'as qu'à approcher ton doigt la
pierre et puis tu vas voir ce que je
vais en faire
oui voilà tu es lyon je vois ta vie mais
c'est à moi maintenant
alors attention moi je suis une porte
oui une porte je suis très malheureuse
parce que je vis dans une maison il ya
beaucoup de portes et beaucoup de
courants d'air parce que les gens qui
habitent cette maison ne ferme jamais
les portes alors tout nous passions une
bonne partie de notre temps a claqué
attention les doigts
je vous laisse imaginer tous les drames
que ça provoque alors fabrice là je
crois que je suis sur la voie sûre que
nos amis sont dans la même situation
ça me paraît pas très difficile à moi
alors moi je suis un petit instrument en
bois ou en plastique pour quoi faire
oui mais mais attention h et je suis
indispensable si on veut faire sécher
son linge sur son balcon ou dans son
jardin
oui si je t'ai pas l'aller les mouchoirs
les chemises les chaussettes
tout ça ça sent vaudrait chez le voisin
et il n'y aurait plus qu'à recommencer
la lessive
alors alors surtout ne me repr ise pas
quand je sais bien je ne vaux pas très
cher je suis même très très bon marché
mais je rend bien des services à croyez
moi fabrice alors alors pensez que vous
vous allez nous coller fait oui oui et
moi venant sans pouvoir répondre à ça
alors ils nous prennent vraiment pour
des lamentables
c'est facile toi tu es un crabe pendant
et depuis accra tu as une porte bel bel
oui et toi si j'ai bien compris alors
bah ça passe tous à mes enfants le cra
pince la porte parce et la pince à linge
je crois oui moi je m'en vais parce que
j'ai des choses à tous à leur chat moi
là bas c'est mon jeu tu sais c'est ton
jeu bah oui tu étais d'accord on a joué
tous d'accord bon alors alors cette
semaine c'est un beau en neuf lettres
bon alors je vais écrire en neuf lettres
mes habitudes comme d'habitude ils
tablent au théâtre en laye ont jusqu il
faut bon comme toujours
alors en neuf lettres la biblio très
longtemps à banneux fleith je t'écoute
alors la première lettre
oui la première lettre c'est un c
décidément ils adorent également
j'aime bien les voiles l'essai s'est
très bien alors tu fais cette petite
raie alors un qui remplace les lettres
de l'enquêté 1 2 3 4
ça c'est plat et la dernière lettre
c'est un e 1 e e
voilà un bien il écrit bien au jeu
extrêmement bien qui est bien ce à bord
alors maintenant tu me pose des
questions si tu veux plus te répond
alors j'étais un animal
ah non non pas lundi non non si noah n'a
ni mater pas un homme dont on célèbre ce
n'est pas une femme célèbre non non non
non c'est pas tout c'est pas c'est une
couleur peut donc c'est pas une longueur
une couleur à tous pas quand est-ce que
cette un objet fabriqué par les hommes
en usine au nous on nous le montre
toi tu aimes bien que tous les gens de
tout des forêts toit n'avait pas et
c'est normal c'est une lenteur à ce
serait assez pas loin mais c'est pas si
c'est une parole claude à allah la tête
à 9 heures il adore ça si on est déçu on
veille des retrouvailles donnez leur la
troisième lettre tu veux la troisième la
deuxième lettre un oui la 3e net c'est
un p 1 pb à la main d'un troisième étape
et voilà ap oui voilà un arrive à
trouver
d'ailleurs s'il avait une petite fille
tu pourrais l'appeler comme ça c'est
vrai avec un prénom elles sont aussi sur
wii aaa devrait peut-être que je trouve
la couleur de ses fleurs
est-ce que c'est blanc abbas à la
couleur oui ou encore pris ce que tu en
penses tout enfant moi je lui donnerai
peut-être encore une indication avant
d'accord savait pas très bien la couleur
de cette fleur finalement à sémalens
quand j'y connais pas grand chose en
fleurs on est mal partis tous les
secteurs dans les bleus vers loin c'est
une grosse fleur annonce une belle
petite fleur une petite fleur énorme les
prenons mais elle est très belle
allez vous êtes sûr je la connais pas ce
que directement aucune flamme
je suis nulle dans gran le civet si tu
la connais il menait alors attends ça
vaut pour être un coquelicot possible
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme fleur qui
commence pas c'est à si j'avais atteint
forgeux conklin
non ça va pas non parce que je pensais à
quoi je pense c'est l'as salé capucine
et ben voilà c'est ça hein ça va
commencer sa fille capucine fait au pe 2
syn1 voilà comment de dosettes à
capucine
ah oui mais comment vous avoue que je
trouve capucine chacun pourrait vous le
dire vous savez très bien capucine ça
s'écrit comme ça donc ça va pas c'est
alors qu'a pu ça jusqu ici et ben ouais
c'est i n -e
c'est la fin c'est assez bon si c'est un
génie c'est avec 2 et toi c'est pas
possible
pour revoir leurs taux grave ça va très
très mal quand à toi tout con quand tu
fais le firent mais tu ne l'a pas aidé
du tout et rien à voir
moi moi moi je trouve que c'était plus
joli avec deux aces
oui je suis jolie mais ça s'écrit comme
sa famille sache écrire tout comme en
tout cas moi ça ne m'empêchera pas de
continuer à les aimer les capucines oui
parce que ce qui m'amuse c'est qu'on
peut manger leurs graines
ah bon ah oui mais quand on a fleuré
fans et il reste une grosse graine qu'on
met dans un bocal avec du vinaigre
pendant pendant plusieurs semaines
bien après on les mange oui oui c'est
comme les comme les choses vertes là
comment ça s'appelle comme les
cornichons
oui c'est bon tu sais tu verras tu
verras je t'en serai goûter un jour tu
verras ça ferait très bon dieu oui mais
je ne savais pas du tout cette histoire
merci de me l'apprendre merci
obama a fait danser la danse pour moi
mais tu es vite
mettez-vous g vous attend il nous
entraîne toi fabrice de noix la nar ont
pas cautionner les dix sièges dans six
mois dans six à huit est bien très très
doux et veillé blessé dans le bas haut
bas haut quelle pitié je viens d'être
exécuté une danse grecque
figure toi que j'ai passé plusieurs
semaines à athènes j'ai eu le privilège
d'être admise à l'école du sirtaki
j'en suis sorti avec le prix
d'excellence
ça me fait tellement plaisir tu pourrais
pas m'apprendre
oh oui oh oui s'il te plaît une autre
fois non je ne veux pas avoir de témoins
des gens qui se moquent qu'ils veulent
qui je veux parler pas du tout mon poids
grèce la grèce ça ça me dit quelque
chose
ah mais oui ça y est je me souviens
l'année dernière dans un jardin j'ai
rencontré une tortue grecque
ouais ouais elle me parlait souvent de
son pays elle regrettait bien le climat
roger la brouille imaginez ciel toujours
bleu le soleil la mer la chaleur enfin
l'été en hiver tout est différent
l'un de mes bons amis aristote pas
populus m'a raconté que dès le mois
d'octobre il se met à pleuvoir
puis à neiger et même âge les aristos tu
as fait passer un iceberg au large de
l'île de mykonos quand j'étais en
juillet-août l'iceberg a défendu une
chance à ces crépuscule ses longues
promenades sur l'acropole et les
mutuelles et aux caps union dis donc
pourquoi tu nous as tu nous envoies
jamais d'art postal
on serait heureux nous d'avoir de tes
nouvelles et là bas tu sais j'aime bien
regarder les belles images mais je vous
en envoie toujours je me déplace
beaucoup mais cela ne m'empêche pas de
penser à mes amis que je me revois vous
écrivant j'étais à athènes dans ma
chambre d'hôtel cette carte eux
représentés à temps voyons je crois que
j'aime l'isthme de corinthe
ah non le défilé des thermopyles c'est
ça oui ah non j'y suis les ruines
démissionner elle l'était super j'ai
besoin d'elle ma parole
hélas vous ne la verrez jamais battu tu
pourrais pas nous la raconter non fermé
les yeux alors fabrice tout le monde je
ferme les yeux
oui mon petit avant goût très bien
lorsque des montagnes à perte de vue
couverte de forêts de bouleaux à aller
boulot break il donne aux paysages un
cachet et au milieu de cette végétation
se devine les ruines du palais
d'agamemnon mais quel dommage c'est
vraiment scandaleux que l'on ait permis
aux prospecteurs de pétrole de s'établir
dans une région comme celle ci mais lors
des rixes gauche l'a vu
de quoi tu parles puis en pétrole quoi
tout le monde recherche quelques-uns ont
tout le pétrole qui sait ce que c'est
pétrole pétrole le pétrole oui le pétrin
oui est parfaitement en droit de risque
du pétrole ont glissé puisque c'est le
début du pétrole à l'avant et non je
sens quelque chose je sens au doute
oui c'est trop fort car tu ne crois
jamais mais si ce qu'elles soient
claires mais non je te crois enfin
belles belles belles belles belles
belles années 30 est invraisemblable est
dans un état riche fabry on regarde
poste motion ce rien pousse mon chum
c'est rien mon petit bonhomme alors tu
la connais elle me faut c'est à chaque
fois sur dix en temps un pousse pousse
et urbain et 20 pouces moussu jeu tu
s'il te plaît pouces moussu ça n'est
rien vérité on a essayé de ne pas la
contrarie aujourd'hui vous avez remarqué
comme moi qu'elles racontent n'importe
quoi sur la grèce
des gamins petit peu étourdi parce que
elle parle à toute vitesse j'étais très
nerveuse comme ça mais a tout de même
des choses qui sont aux oreilles enfin
vous avez déjà vu en grèce du pétrole
revue du pétrole avec des derricks en
grèce en californie peut-être au texas
mais en grèce franchement dans les pays
d'aramits elle nous a parlé tous que ce
qu'elle m'a dit il manie les boulots on
les boulots est ce qu'il ya des boulots
en grèce soit un pays du sud alors que
les boulots sont dans les forêts du nord
et puis ce ciel alors cet hiver grecque
vous imaginez cet hiver grecque avec de
la neige à et de la banquise au large de
lagos à qui elle a parlé d'un risque
j'écoute alors que c'est un climat
paradisiaque merveilleux et fait
toujours beau le ciel est bleu est lourd
non c'est pas possible dit vraiment
absolument n'importe quoi elle n'est
jamais en reste ma vie enfin moi je vous
dis en prenant prochaine fois on fera
semblant l'écouteront encore amicalement
mais dis donc pour smooth eu ça ferait
rien de te réveiller un petit peu bonbon
est ce que tu pourrais répéter ce que je
viens de dire un boulot le pétrole et le
ciel bleu de grèce en cas ni neige ni
banquise derrière du tout qui fait au
contraire très sec
tu pourras va péter ça sur la grèce et
d'ennui pas fabriquer ailleurs alors toi
allez rendors toi voir cet abri ce oui
tu veux qu'on joue un petit peu au lude
eu un petit coup de l'union oui avant de
se quitter
allez d'accord je vais refaire un petit
peu de l'idiot avant que nous séparions
je vous rappelle que c'est très simple
un bocal avec de l'eau une ampoule dont
on à vider petit à petit goutte-à-goutte
le liquide qui se trouvaient à
l'intérieur c'était une ampoule d'eau
distillée jusqu'à ce qu'on obtienne cet
équilibre qui permet à laon poule de
rester la surface comment ça marche
et bien comme ceci regardez bien puis la
paume et si tout va bien le l'union ira
jusqu'aux font attention up et voilà le
ludion est au fond je veux faire
remonter encore une fois vous pouvez
faire la même chose chez vous si vous
avez quelques petits problèmes vous
demander de l'aide à votre papa ou à
votre moment et par l'ombre ça marche
pas à tous les coups faut bien l'appuyer
et cette fois ci c'est parfait on va à
tous et à bientôt
[Musique]